hi my name is rawson marshall thurber
and i'm here to talk to you all about
what it's like to work with Dwayne
Johnson spoiler alert it's awful just
kidding
it's super-fun and we're gonna talk
about a particular scene from the movie
in the scene breakdown I hope you
brought your popcorn what we're about to
see is a key sequence in the picture in
which Dwayne's character will Sawyer is
desperately trying to get into a burning
building his family's trapped above the
fire line and there's no other way for
him to get in but to make a leap off a
super crane so this this point right
here oh he's trapped and now he has to
decide what to do right here is one of
my favorite shots in the whole sequence
now the only thing that's real here is
Dwayne Johnson and the thing he's
standing on and this light here is
actually not attached to a helicopter
it's a big xenon light that's basically
on a crane and we lift it up and the
wizards at ILM put in the helicopter
later so that doesn't exist you add a
little bit of wind a little bit of
camera shake and suddenly have yourself
an action sequence in this moment right
here that you're about to see the most
important thing is not the giant super
crane not the giant building not the the
fire not the helicopter but it's Dwayne
Johnson's eyes this is the moment he has
to decide what he's gonna do
this moment borrows heavily from the
fugitive there's this great moment in
Harrison Ford is caught by Tommy Lee
Jones and he has to decide what he's
gonna do he can either get arrested and
go back to prison for the rest of his
life or he can take a swan dive a storm
drain down the 300-foot fall
this part here Dwayne worked really hard
on on matching the gait of an amputee
there's a very specific cadence to the
run and he worked a lot with Jeff glass
Brenner the first amputee ever to climb
Mount Everest was the inspiration for a
lot of the character will Sawyer we
actually when we shot it on set
Jeff glass burner was there and give us
two thumbs up and was really blown away
by the authenticity of the gate and then
Jeff talked to the entire crew an
amputee that's gonna show people that is
kick-ass to be an amputee you can get to
any summit you can do anything in life
but you got to have it in here and you
got to have it here I thank you guys so
much
had he not lost his leg he says he never
would have climbed Mount Everest he
probably would have stayed in Wisconsin
as a farmer for his whole life I've
never climbed Mount Everest and I've got
both legs so let's go see what I know
and so here comes Dwayne down the super
crane who doesn't want to see this
everybody and then here so a little bit
about the length of this jump there's
been spend some talk about it certainly
on our poster our friends and marketing
bless them may have exaggerated the
length a little bit so here this is
actually physically possible to achieve
now is it physically possible to achieve
if you're 265 pound man missing your
lower left leg maybe that but if I had
to lay my money on one person it would
be doing Johnson the other thing to talk
about here we shot this on a stage and
the only thing that's real in this
entire frame is the actual super crane
itself which you can see right here and
this little guy right here that's Dwayne
Johnson
there's no CGI Dwayne in this hole in
this whole sequence we do have his great
stunt double tunnel I read in a couple
spots this super super wide shot I
believe that to a double nitendo I read
that's obviously real Dwayne that's
nobody
that's real Lane that's real doing
what's interesting about this one is
this is tena why with a little bit of
face replacement on Dewayne
that's actually not facial listen I
forgot this is 1000 right here that's
not real doing that's the stunt double
but you'd never know so this is stunt
double stunt double stunt double now we
blend and now we're in a different shot
now this is real Dwayne right here
thanks for watching this exclusive clip
of my movie skyscraper which comes out
July 13th please buy your ticket and
don't forget to buy it on Fandango